if you watched any blockbuster comedies
from 2001 to 2008 odds are decent you
enjoyed the comic stylings of Mr Ben
Stiller and for good reason the now
legendary writer actor director has been
churning out hilarious movies for a long
time but he wasn't alone Stiller wisely
worked alongside the comic stylings of
what is often referred to as the Frat
pack in several of his biggest projects
of that era we're talking hits like Meet
the Parents Zoolander tropic Thunder Etc
the Frat pack was originally considered
to be will frell Jack Black Vince vaugh
Luke Wilson and Owen Wilson and then the
likes of Steve Carell John C Riley and
David Kenner were added in it wasn't an
official group per se just a fun way to
think about the mix and match of comedic
Powerhouse talent that seem to enjoy
working together stick around as we go
through some classic Ben Stiller movies
to look out which frat pack members he
shared the screen with if you haven't
seen 2004's hilarious Star Ski in Hutch
you'd be wise to do
it do it it's a great remake of the
classic TV series though the influence
of Ben Stiller and the Frat pack ensured
that it was a much more comedic take
than the original though to be fair it
still had its share of action sequences
including some pretty welldone car
chases in the car made famous by the
show a 1976 Ford Grand Torino the titel
stari and Hut are played by Stiller and
Owen Wilson respectively and they were a
comedic force to be reckoned with they
played off each other brilliantly often
in pretty ridiculous costumes rounding
out the Frat pack presence was the
always seen stealing will frell as an
inmate informant Big Earl and Vince
vaugh as the movie's main baddy Reese
Feldman vaugh had to play his role
fairly grounded so that the over-the-top
antics of Stiller and Wilson could shine
through the act like a dragon scene
alone is worth it though it's probably a
little too risque for this video so
we'll let you Google that one on your
own 2001's Zoolander is arguably the
movie that put Ben Stiller on the map
it's an absurd Take On The World of
fashion International Espionage and
orange MOA
fro Stiller plays a male model who is
well a real dum dum and yet he's so
ridiculously goodlook he can't help but
be a huge star of course he has his
moment of Doubt did you ever think that
maybe there's more to life than being
ridiculously good-looking this is
especially true when he gets involved in
a plot to kill the prime minister of
Malaysia trust me it makes sense in the
zany world of Zoolander once again
joining him as his sidekick is Owen
Wilson who plays Hansel another world
famous male model and Stiller's real
life wife Christine Taylor plays an
investigative journalist trying to break
the story once again Stiller and Wilson
are join joined by Will frell and Vince
vaugh this time frell gets to play the
main bad guy though true to form he
plays his character way over the top and
it's awesome are you not aware that I
get farty and Bloated with a foamy latte
V's role is pretty small which isn't too
surprising given that he was less of a
big name way back then but he plays
zoolander's coal miner brother and has a
funny scene in a bar with Stiller and
John Voit who plays their dad Meet the
Parents is another of the classic still
movies that seems to be rif with ever
quotable moments if you've ever heard
anyone say I have nipples Greg could you
milk me that's what they're quoting from
it's the tale of a guy named Greg who
after getting engaged travels to meet
his fiance's parents for the first time
it's a classic story we've all been
through where her father is a secret CIA
agent who spends the weekend trying to
harass and interrogate you no just me
okay then Robert dairo has an incredible
turn as Jack Burns the parent in
question and Stiller gets to play the
dialed down Greg character who's just
trying to survive the visit the other
frat pack member is Owen Wilson are we
sensing a pattern here he plays The Uber
successful ex-boyfriend of Pam the
fiance and while there aren't a ton of
scenes with the two of them it's still
comedy gold Meet the Parents was a
blockbuster hit raking in over $330
million worldwide so naturally they had
to make a sequel and despite perhaps not
being quite as good as the original it's
still a fun ride and it earned 522
million bucks at the box office so
everyone was happy and I'm sure Ben
Stiller was happy to be rejoined with
the Fantastic cast including his buddy
Owen Wilson they both played the same
characters of course and when they saw
each other they were probably like
manishma which is Hebrew for what's
going on joining the fun this time were
Legends Barbara Strand and Dustin
Hoffman as Greg's parents adding to the
overall all neurosis and hilarity of the
movie now I can't go too long without
hearing someone say if you can dodge a
wrench you can dodge a ball if you can
dodge a wrench you can dodge a
ball see what I mean that gem is from
the Appley named dodgeball an Underdog
Story which follows the tale of a Vince
Von Le rag tag group of dodgeball
players they're trying to win a big
tournament to save the gym they love
it's the Bad News Bears meets Well
Middle School gym class Vince plays the
down to earth and slightly sarcastic
lead Peter laflor and this time Stiller
gets to play the insane over-the-top
villain white Goodman he's the owner of
the Rival gym looking to win the
tournament and own both gyms it's a frat
pack battle to see who can best follow
the five DS of dodgeball Dodge duck dip
dive and Dodge finally we have Tropic
Thunder a movie that saw Ben Stiller and
another frat pack buddy Jack Black they
they play two actors a reach I know who
are filming an action movie in the
jungles of the Golden Triangle where
Thailand Laos and Myanmar meet but
unbeknownst to them they accidentally
get involved in a real life battle
against a local drug ring they think
it's all part of the movie they bravely
fight back act tough say py onliners and
the rest but eventually they realize
they're in actual danger it's a
hilarious send up of Hollywood and a
great watch if nothing else to see Iron
Man himself Robert Downey Jr say this
line I know who I am I'm a dude playing
a dude disguises another dude when it
comes to rewatchable movies pretty much
every one of these qualifies I can sit
and do a marathon of all these and the
only thing I'd need are some solid
snacks and a few bathroom breaks okay
maybe one break for some sunshine got to
get that vitamin D people have any
thoughts about the Frat pack or these
classic comedies pop them in the
comments
section